Next up, every night across America,
90 million people are up to the same thing at night.
It's snoring!
(audience laughing)
Either you or someone in your house
is playing that sweet nose music, nightly.
But how much can you take?
A study finds, a new survey found that the average person
can only stand it for about 90 minutes
before they kick their partner outta bed.
Or, I mean, I'm assuming,
have probably move,
you know, to the couch or somewhere else.
Yeah.
Does Ross, Rossy, do you or Wellie snore?
How dare you? I feel attacked.
(laughing)
It's so funny, when you said snore,
I was looking at our audience
and there are bunch of people here with their significance.
And a lot of people went like this.
Too late, I'm looking at you.
(audience claps)
You know, what are you gonna do?
I don't know.
But someone in the audience also deals with this dilemma.
Jaffa, are you in our audience?
Jaffa.
Hi, Drew. Hey, Ross.
Hi.
What is your snore story?
(sighs)
Well, my boyfriend snores so loud,
It really makes me wanna kick him to the couch.
I love the guy, I do,
but a girl needs her beauty sleep too.
Yes.
What do you do?
I end up on the couch.
(Drew gasps)
Have you brought it up?
Well, he's right here. Maybe I can bring it up.
Wait, what!
How do you live through this?
Because everyone's gotta live through something
with someone.
So, your thing is snoring.
Okay, so now what do you do?
So, Drew, Ross,
obviously, I mean, I think I'm gonna get in trouble
when I get home.
But...
So the thing is,
I think you're already in a trouble.
(laughs)
The idea is to get her out of the bed
so I can have the whole bed to myself.
(gasps)
So,
You better be careful,
she might just be out of that bed for good.
(laughs)
Wait, are you faking it?
Yeah, I was faking it. That's the thing.
(laughing)
Sometimes you just wanna like, lay back, relax,
turn on Netflix, maybe watch a movie on your own.
But seriously, are you serious?
Are you messing with her?
Obviously, I'm messing with her.
Gosh! Darn you!
I really fell for that.
And I was like, oh no!
Don't do that.
Oh my god! I'm so relieved.
Okay, so everything's okay.
You're not being duplicitous
and we're not plotting your death on the way home.
No, Of course not.
Right, well, this is good news.
Can you do an impression of how bad the snoring is?
Do you want me to embarrass you?
Yeah.
Just show us, so we get an idea.
We're not asking, you owe it to me.
(snores)
(laughing)
Yeah. Good luck, you guys.
Thank you guys. Thank you.
You're welcome.
Okay. Next story.
God, that really gave me an anxiety attack.
Worried you.
Hey, Drew, next, We have a story,
I know you're gonna love.
Do you guys remember having that big CD collection
back in the day?
Well, a writer at Rolling Stone named Rob Sheffield,
he just wrote a love letter to the CD.
Last year, CD sales actually increased
for the first time in 17 years.
How?
Well, they say mostly thanks to Adele, BTS and Taylor Swift.
But Rob is hoping for a major CD comeback.
Okay, you guys have to look at what she's doing over here.
She's bringing out, she...
Oh my god! It's so heavy, I'm not kidding.
Drew commits to a story.
(audience clapping)
She brought in her CD book.
You still have your CDs?
Yeah.
Look it opened right up to De La Soul.
And are these alphabetized?
They're alphabetized and yeah, every book I have A to Z.
I just have to say, the most shocking thing
about this story is how well organized your CDs are.
Because look at the desk
and look at her CDs.
Barrymore, I'm proud of you.
There's hope for everybody.
Very proud of you.
(upbeat music)